we're told given g of x is equal to 10
of x minus 3 pi over 2 plus 6. find g
inverse of x and they want us to type
that in here and then they also want us
to figure out what is the domain of g
inverse the domain of g inverse of x so
i've got my little
scratch pad here to try to work that
through so let's let's figure out what g
inverse of x is this is g of x
so g inverse of x i'm essentially let me
just read this is g of x right over here
g of x is equal to tangent of x minus 3
pi over 2 plus 6. so g inverse of x i
essentially can swap the i can replace
the x with the g inverse of x and
replace the g of x with an x and then
solve for g inverse of x so i could
write that x
is equal to tangent
of
g inverse of
g inverse
g inverse of x
minus 3 pi
over 2
plus
plus 6. so let's just solve for g
inverse of x i actually encourage you to
pause this video and try to work through
this out or work work it out on your own
so let's subtract 6 from both sides to
to at least get rid of this 6 here and
so i'm left with x minus 6 is equal to
the tangent
of g
inverse of x
minus 3 pi
over 2.
now let's take the inverse tangent of
both sides of this equation so the
inverse tangent of the left-hand side is
the inverse
tangent of x minus 6. and on the right
hand side the inverse tangent of tangent
if we restrict the domain in the proper
way and we'll talk about that a little
bit is just going to be what the input
into the tangent function is so if you
restrict the domain in the right way
tangent the
inverse tangent of the tangent
of
something of say theta is just going to
be equal to
theta once again if we restrict the
domain if we restrict what the possible
values of theta are in the right way
so let's just assume that we're doing
that and so this is going the inverse
tangent of the tan of this is going to
be just this stuff right over here it's
just going to be that it's going to be g
inverse
of x
minus 3 pi
over 2 and now we're in the home stretch
to solve for g inverse of x we could
just add 3 pi over 2 to both sides so we
get and actually let me just swap both
sides we get g inverse
of x
is equal to
the inverse tangent
of x minus 6 and then we're adding 3 pi
over 2 to both sides so this side is now
on that or this side's now on this side
so plus 3 pi over 2
plus
3 pi
over
2. so let me let me actually type that
in let me see if i can remember it so
because i'm about to lose this on my
screen so inverse tangent of x minus 6
plus 3 pi over 2. so let me write that
down so let me type this so g inverse of
x is going to be the inverse
the inverse tangent so i could write it
like this the inverse tangent
of x minus six and yes it interpreted it
correctly inverse tangent you can view
that as arc tangent of x minus six
plus three pi over two and it did
interpret it correctly but then we have
to think about what is the domain of g
inverse what is the domain of g inverse
of x let's think about this a little bit
more the domain of g inverse of x so
let's just think about what tangent is
doing
so the tangent function if we imagine a
unit circle
if we imagine a unit circle so that's a
unit circle right over there i guess we
can imagine it to be a unit circle
my pen tool is acting up a little bit
it's putting these little gaps and
things but i think we can
power through that so let's just say for
the sake of argument that that's a unit
circle that's the x-axis and that's the
y-axis if you form an angle theta
if you form some angle theta right over
here
the the tangent of theta is essentially
the slope of this terminal ray of the
angle or the the the yeah i guess you
could call it the terminal ray of the
angle the angles formed by that ray and
this ray along the positive x-axis so
the tangent of theta is the slope right
over there
is the slope right over there and you
can get a tangent of any theta except
for a few
so you can find the tangent of that you
could find the slope there you could
find the slope there you could also find
the slope there
you could find the slope there but the
place where you can't find the slope is
when this ray goes straight up
is when this ray goes straight up or
this ray goes straight down those are
the cases where you can't find the slope
there the slope you could say is
approaching positive or negative
infinity so the domain of tangent
so tangents
tangent domain
so the domain
is essentially
all real numbers
all
reals
except
multiples of pi over
i guess you could say pi over 2 plus
multiples of pi
except pi over 2
plus multiples of pi where k could be
any integer so you could also be
subtracting pi because if you have pi
over 2 if you add pi you go straight
down here you add another pi you go up
there if you subtract pi you go down
here add subtract another pi you go over
there so these are this is the domain
but you can but given this domain you
can get any real number
so the range
the range here
is all
all reals
because you can get any slope here you
can
increase theta if you want a really high
slope decrease theta if you want a
really negative slope right over there
so you can really get to anything
now when you're talking about the
inverse tangent when you're talking
about the inverse tangent
by convention you're going to well to
make tangent invertible so that you
don't have multiple elements of your
domain all mapping to the same element
of the range because for example
this angle right over here has the exact
same slope as
as this angle right over here
right over here and so if you have two
thetas mapping to the same tangent then
that's not if you don't restrict your
domain so that you only have one of them
it's not going to be invertible and so
the convention the convention is is that
to make tangent invertible you restrict
its domain
so you restrict the domain
restrict
the domain
to the interval
from negative pi over 2
to pi over 2 in order to construct the
inverse tangent so the inverse tangent
you can input any any real number into
it so the inverse tangent's domain
domain this is just a convention they
could have picked they could have
restricted tangents domains as long as
for any theta it or there's only one
theta in that in that domain that maps
to a specific element of the range but
the the convention is well inverse
tangent can or
the convention is to restrict tangent's
domain between negative pi over two and
pi over two so inverse tangent's domain
is all reals
all reals
but its range is restricted
its range and this is by convention it's
going to be between negative pi over 2
and pi over 2 and not including and not
including them so let's go back to our
original question right over here what
is the domain
of g inverse so let's look at let's look
at our
the domain of g inverse well g inverse
the domain of this i could put any real
number in here
any
any real number here now what this is
going to pop out is going to be
something between negative pi over 2 and
pi over 2 but they're not asking us the
range of g inverse
actually would have been a more
interesting question
they're asking us what's the domain of g
inverse and i could put in any real
number right here for x so let's put
that in here so the domain of g inverse
of x it's negative infinity to infinity
but actually just just for fun and let's
just verify that we got the question
right and we did but just for fun
actually i am curious let's just think
about what the range of g inverse is so
the range of this thing right over here
is going to be between
negative
pi over 2 to pi over 2
that's for this part right over here and
then we're going to add 3 pi over 2s to
it
so the range for the entire function
so the range for this thing
the range
is going to be what the low end if we
add 3 pi over 2 to this this is going to
give us 2 pi over 2 which is just going
to be so 3 pi over 2 minus pi over 2 is
going to be 2 pi over 2 which is just pi
just pi all the way to 3 pi over 2 plus
another pi over 2 is going to be 4 pi's
over 2 or 2 pi
or 2 pi so the range of g inverse of x
is pi
to 2 pi
and and it's an open interval it doesn't
include the boundaries
but its domain you could put any value
for x here and it will be defined